good morning Hank it's Monday I'm in an
airport fancy that I like balls I'm on
my way to Munich and I've been thinking
about an opportunity you missed
presumably intentionally I'm trying to
record a video hey hold on first I got
to go to Munich then Here I am took me
longer than it took you I know what
you're wondering Hank John did you sleep
on the plane I did not so here it is one
day later but zero hours sleep
fortunately my hotel has welcome body
and hair shampoo I washed my body in my
hair with the same product welcome also
nerdfighters that you live in Munich
come see me later this week
and if you live in London or Edinboro
next month more info in the I'm tired I
assume that I'm fart means bad right
what was I talking about balls right
balls so we can your video on Friday you
revealed that you have two fun balls
from the VidCon ball pit signed by Shane
Dawson which as you point out in the
video means that technically Shane
Dawson has signed your balls now like I
realize that I'm stating the obvious
here but if you title that video Shane
Dawson signed my balls then you put up a
high contrast thumbnail of Shane
Dawson's face that video is more or less
guaranteed to get 10 million balls views
I'm introduced I'm very tired
walk with me so anyway your decision not
to call that video Shane Dawson signed
my balls seemed to me almost heroic well
I don't want to blow it out of
proportion the day after Nelson
Mandela's 92nd birthday may be heroic
isn't quite the right word but the fact
is that the prevailing belief on the
Internet and in television and in movies
is that all views are good views now
like we don't exactly have the moral
high ground on this subject given that
our three most viewed videos are in
order
giraffe sex giraffe sex and giraffe sex
but your bold choice not to call your
Friday video my balls got signed by
Shane Dawson reminded me that while I
like balls we are not in the balls
business we are in the nerdfighting
business that's why I make videos and
why write books and why I'm in Munich
because I like doing awesome stuff with
awesome people and that's why my
proudest day as a nerdfighter came last
week not when the vlogbrothers hit 300
thousand subscribers but when the
nerdfighters came together with Esther
and helped the Harry Potter Alliance win
$250,000 that's what our community does
and while there is a place in this world
for like
balls and giraffe sex that's our real
work Hank thanks for reminding me of
that and nerdfighters thanks again for
voting with Esther to win the Harry
Potter Alliance $250,000 French of the
llama
Hank I'm sure you'll let me know what my
punishment is on Wednesday well that's
certainly the hairiest Jesus I've ever
seen